TO BE,
YOU NEVER WANT TO BE SACKED
THAT MANY TIMES, YOU KNOW, 400
TIMES
I'LL BASICALLY IS IS WAY TOO
MANY
402, MANY, YOU KNOW. SO I
THINK THAT'S A BIG BIG THING
THAT WE
GOTTA FIX. THAT'S GOT TO BE
FIXED. WELL, WE GOT TO GET
BETTER UP FOR ANYTHING THAT
IT'S NOT JUST PASSING. I
THINK
IN TERMS OF EVERYTHING YOU DO,
YOU KNOW, YOU
IT CONTROLS THE GAME WITH THE
COMMENTS YOU MADE ABOUT THE
OFFENSIVE LINE AND BEING
QUESTIONED WAS GETTING HIT
THE, YOU MEAN THAT IT'S SORT
OF A DIRECT CRITICISM THAT
IDEA OFFENSIVE LINE IN GENERAL
NOT NOT AT ALL ABOUT THE
OFFICE AND I THINK THAT I ALSO
ALSO
MENTION HIM INTO. YEAH, I
THAT YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS
IS THAT I CAN DO BETTER TO YOU
KNOW, I THINK THAT'S WE'RE ALL
ALL TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO WIN
ALL TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO BE
BETTER.
RUSSELL WILSON AND EVENTFUL.
OFFSEASON FOR HIM.
HE COMES IN AT NUMBER FIVE ON
THE CHRIS SIMMS, TOP 40
QUARTERBACK COUNTDOWN
DOWNS. TWO SPOTS. YEAH.
FROM NUMBER THREE.
NUMBER TWO, WE STARTED LAST
YEAR LAST YEAR. HE WAS NUMBER
TWO.
YEAH, I MADE THEM THREE WHEN
WE DID THAT WEEK, 10, KIND
OF,
YOU KNOW, RE-RANK LAST YEAR.
BUT YES,
YOU KNOW,
STILL PHENOMENAL. WE KNOW THAT
STILL ONE OF THE BEST
QUARTERBACKS IN THE GAME.
I MEAN CAPTAIN CLUTCH
AS FAR AS ALL, THAT
STUFF IS CONCERNED.
AWESOME DEEP.
ALL THROWER, EVERYTHING LIKE
THAT.
YEAH. WE HAD SOME OTHER GUYS
THAT ARE REALLY GOOD
QUARTERBACKS TO WHO JUMP THEM,
AND WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THEM IN A FEW MINUTES BUT MAN
RUSSELL WILSON, YOU KNOW,
STILL
BIG-TIME PLAYER
BIG TIME PLAY MAKER,
YOU KNOW, CAN OF COURSE,
EXTEND PLAYS. HE'S NOT
QUITE THE RUNNER, HE USED TO
BE
OR THE EXTENDER OF PLAYS THAT
HE USED TO BE
BUT IT'S STILL REALLY HIGH
LEVEL STUFF
AND HE IS WITHOUT A DOUBT
STILL ONE OF THE BEST
QUARTERBACKS IN THIS IN THIS
GAME.
HANG ON. YEAH, WHY DO YOU
THINK HE CAN'T RUN LIKE
HE USED TO? IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S
40.
NO, NO, I KNOW, BUT IT'S NOT,
IT'S NOT THE SAME RUSSELL
WILSON FROM
THREE, FOUR,
FIVE YEARS AGO NOW HE STILL
CAN RUN BUT I DON'T FEEL LIKE
HIS.
I FEEL LIKE OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
PASSED HIM UP FOR MAYBE
BEING BETTER RUNNERS AND
SCRAMBLERS THAN HE HAD. AND
THEN HE IS, I GUESS IS WHAT
I'M SAYING,
YOU KNOW. YEAH, THERE'S A FEW
OUT THERE, IT'S STILL REALLY
GOOD. DON'T GET ME WRONG. I
JUST DON'T
DON'T FEEL LIKE HE'S
AS EXPLOSIVE AS HE WAS,
THAT'S WHY I AM MAKING A GOOD
POINT, YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT
LIKE
YOU. HEY
RUSSELL, WILSON'S REALLY FAST
AND HERE COMES KYLE AND MARIE
AND YOU FORGET ABOUT RUSSELL
WILSON BEING FAST BECAUSE
COLLAR MURRAY'S FASTER. YEAH,
YEAH. IT'S NOT LIKE, YEAH,
EXACTLY. I'M NOT TRYING TO
MAKE AN INDICTMENT ON RUSSELL
WAS SOMEWHAT. I'M GOING LIKE,
YEAH, HE'S NOT AS FAST AS HE
ONCE WAS, THERE'S KYLER
MURRAY, THERE'S LAMAR JACKSON.
THERE'S THE SEAN WATSON.
THERE'S JOSH ALAN. THEY'RE
BOTH TO ME. THOSE GUYS ARE
BETTER RUNNERS IN HIM NOW, SO
THEY'VE KIND OF PASSED HIM UP
IN THAT DEPARTMENT.
SO
THAT'S HOW
I WOULD LOOK AT IT. BUT MAN,
I MEAN RUSSELL WILSON. WE KNOW
THERE'S BEEN LIMITATIONS IN
THAT OFFENSE, IT'S NOT ALWAYS
QUARTERBACK FRIENDLY,
IT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY TO PLAY
QUARTERBACK THERE IN SEATTLE,
WITH A DEFENSE, A HEAD COACH
AND ALL THOSE TYPE OF THINGS,
HE MAKES A NUMBER OF BIG TIME
THROWS. BUT LAST YEAR, I WILL
SAY THAT THERE WERE
MOMENTS WHERE, YOU KNOW,
FIRST TIME I EVER SAW HIM GET
A LITTLE RECKLESS, YOU KNOW,
WITH THE FOOTBALL OR MAYBE
IN PATIENT TO A DEGREE
AND THE ONE THING THAT I'LL
SAY NEGATIVE 2 THAT STILL
JUST I'VE ALWAYS SAID THIS BUT
IT'S STILL
JUMPS OUT TO ME.
IS THERE ARE
COMPLETIONS LEFT ON THE FIELD
OF TIMES HE CAN
BE GREEDY AND LOOK FOR MORE
MIKE. HE MIGHT HAVE A
SIX-YARD 8-YARD OUT BY THE
TIGHT END, RIGHT?
HE'LL LOOK AT IT. HE'S OPEN
AND HE'LL KIND OF JUST COCK
THE BALL AND PUMP IT AND
GO. NOW I DON'T WANT TO THROW
IN, HE'LL DANCE AROUND AND DO
SOMETHING AND YOU GO. WELL
MAN, HE WAS OPEN AND WAIT THAT
GUY WAS OPEN AND HE'LL LOOK
FOR SOMETHING BETTER AND, YOU
KNOW, HEY, HE DOES FIND THINGS
BETTER SOMETIMES.
BUT AT TIMES, IT CAN STALL
THEIR OFFENSE OUT TO TO WHERE
YOU GO.
WELL, NO, NOW YOU HAVE TO
THROW THE BALL AWAY, OR YOU
GOT SACKED BECAUSE YOU HELD
ONTO THE BALL LONGER THAN YOU
SHOULD HAVE. AND THOSE ARE
LITTLE THINGS ABOUT HIS GAME
THAT
I THINK BOTHERED ME A LITTLE
LAST YEAR FOR
SURE.
IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT HE WAS
UNHAPPY IN SEATTLE, IT WAS
OBVIOUS THAT HE WANTED OUT. I
DON'T CARE WHAT HE SAYS NOW.
YEAH, BETWEEN HIM AND HIS
AGENT BACK IN FEBRUARY AND
MARCH, IT WAS CLEAR THAT HE
WAS LOOKING FOR A NEW
PLACE TO GO. HE WASN'T HAPPY
WITH THE WAY THINGS HAD GONE
IN SEATTLE, HE WASN'T HAPPY
WITH THE FACT THAT HE ONLY HAS
ONE SUPER BOWL WIN IN HIS
NINE NFL SEASONS. I SAW THAT
ESPN REPORTED AND
BLEACHER REPORT. AMPLIFIED
RUSSELL WILSON IS HAPPY AND
ALL IN
AFTER SEATTLE'S OFFSEASON, MY
REACTION TO THAT IS. HE'S ONLY
ALL IN BECAUSE
COULDN'T GET ALL OUT. YEAH.
AND
THAT STILL LINGERS, AND, AND I
RAISED THAT NOW BECAUSE IT
TRACES
TO THE DESIRE BY RUSSELL
WILSON, TO BE PATRICK
MAHOMES TO BE THE GUY THROUGH
WHOM THE OFFENSE
RUNS. FAIR QUESTION, CHRIS
IS RUSSELL WILSON. GOOD ENOUGH
TO BE THAT GUY. HE IS
GOOD ENOUGH TO BE THAT GUY. I
DON'T THINK HE CAN. I DON'T
THINK HE CAN DO IT
TO THE LEVEL OF
MAHOMES OR JOSH
ALLEN WHO WE HAVE NOT REVEALED
ON THIS RANKING AND THIS LIST
YET EITHER.
I
I DON'T KNOW. NOT AT THIS
POINT OF HIS CAREER,
BUT I STILL THINK THAT YES,
HE COULD STILL BE
IN THAT TYPE OF OFFENSE AND
DELIVER
HIGH END RESULTS AND A LOT OF
BIG-TIME FOOTBALL PLAYS,
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
SO YEAH IT DOES. HE HAVE A
POINT AND MAYBE WANTING THE
OFFENSE TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE RUSSELL? WELL,
WILSON CENTRIC. SURE
HE DOES. I MEAN HE'S LOOKING
AT IT LIKE THOSE GUYS AND HE
WANTS TO PLAY THAT
FREE-FLOWING AWESOME
QUARTERBACK GAME AND I DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
MANAGING ANYTHING.
I CAN JUST DROP BACK AND THROW
THE BALL ALL THE TIME
I GET IT.
BUT YEAH, HE'S UP THERE IN
SEATTLE. THEY PLAY A DIFFERENT
WAY AND I DON'T SEE PETE
CARROLL EVER REALLY BUDGING ON
THAT AT THAT
ASPECT.
YOU KNOW, I THINK ONE OF THE
PRACTICAL REALITIES HERE
AND THIS GETS BACK TO WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT WITH
RELATIVE SPEED. IT'S NOT THAT
HE'S GOTTEN SLOWER,
IT'S THAT FASTER QUARTERBACKS
ARE NOW IN THE LEAGUE. I'LL
BROADEN THAT.
AND SAY IT'S NOT THAT
RUSS HAS DIMINISHED IT. ALL
RIGHT,
BUT
YOU KNOW, FIVE YEARS AGO,
YEAH, IT'S ABSOLUTELY WAS
AARON RODGERS. RUSSELL WILSON,
TOM BRADY. NOW YOU
GOT PATRICK MAHOMES. JOSH
ALAN
LAMAR JACKSON, KYLER MARIE,
WE HAVE
BETTER.
QUARTERBACKS
QUARTERBACKS, WHO ARE
BETTER AS YOUNG
QUARTERBACKS THAN RUSSELL
WILSON WAS AND WILL BE BETTER
IN THEIR PRIMES THAN RUSSELL.
WILSON WAS. SO IT'S NOTHING
ABOUT HIM IS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED,
ITS THAT THE YOUNGER
GUYS
ARE JUST BETTER THAN THEY'VE
EVER BEEN.
SO IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE GUYS
WHO'S ALREADY BEEN THERE,
THEY'RE GOING TO JUMP YOU. AND
THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT IS. AND
THAT MAY HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH THE FACT THAT HE'S AT
NUMBER FIVE. IT IS IT
REALLY IS
A, YOU KNOW, WE
TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT.
A LOT, RIGHT? I MEAN, THERE'S
A LOT OF FREAKY, GOOD
QUARTERBACKS IN THE NFL RIGHT
NOW. WE DON'T HAVE A
QUARTERBACK PROBLEM IN THIS
LEAGUE
WE DON'T AS I'VE ALWAYS SAID
AND YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY, WE
HAVE AN OFFENSIVE COORDINATOR
PROBLEM IN MY OPINION, NOT A
QUARTERBACK PROBLEM YOU KNOW
I THINK A LOT OF QUARTERBACKS
WOULD BE LOOKED AT LOOKED AT A
LOT DIFFERENTLY. IF
WE HAD, YOU KNOW, SOME BETTER
COORDINATORS BEHIND THEM, HE
WOULD GO. WHOA, HE IS PRETTY
GOOD KNOW, HE'S ALWAYS BEEN
GOOD,
HE'S JUST BEEN IN SOME YOU
KNOW CRAPPY
SITUATIONS
AND AND RUSSELL WILSON
CERTAINLY HAS NOT
HAD THE BENEFIT OF
LIKE THE GREATEST
OFFENSES IN THE WORLD, THERE'S
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
HE'S STILL DANGEROUS.
HE'S STILL
ARGUABLY. THE CLUTCHES
QUARTERBACK IN THE GAME. I
MEAN, WHEN RUSSELL WILSON, HAS
THE BALL LATE IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER AND THEY'RE DOWN,
I MEAN IT'S ALMOST SHOCKING
AND MIND-BLOWING IF THEY DON'T
SCORE AND WIN THE GAME AND
THEY
THEY PUT A LOT ON THEM FROM
THAT WAY. I'VE NEVER SEEN A
TEAM,
YOU KNOW TO GIVE HIM MORE
CREDIT
HERE, THAT IS MORE COMFORTABLE
BEING DOWN BY 10 POINTS
WITH NINE MINUTES LEFT IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER AND JUST BEING
LIKE WE JUST WANT TO GIVE THE
BALL TO RUSSELL WITH TWO
MINUTES WITH A CHANCE TO WIN.
I MEAN, IT SEEMS LIKE THEY
PLAY THAT WAY AT TIMES AND
OF COURSE, HEY, I DON'T WANT
TO TAKE TAKE ALSO AND
WE GOT TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
TO, YOU KNOW, HE DID SOME
REALLY GOOD THINGS AND
ESPECIALLY
EARLY THIS YEAR
WHEN THEIR DEFENSE WAS ON PACE
TO BE THE WORST DEFENSE
IN THE HISTORY OF
FOOTBALL. I MEAN HE DID DO
MADE SOME INCREDIBLE PLAYS WAS
PLAYING AT A REALLY HIGH
LEVEL
SO WE'RE STILL LIKE THAT'S
WHY I DON'T WANT THIS TO BE A
DEMEANING THING ON RUSSELL
WILSON. I'M GLAD YOU'RE KIND
OF SAYING THAT WHAT I WANTED
TO SAY, THEY'RE JUST SOME
REALLY OTHER GOOD QUARTERBACKS
THAT I THINK HAVE JUST
SURPASSED HIM A LITTLE BIT
HERE IN THE LAST
YEAR.
YEAH, I MEAN, I REALLY DO
THINK THAT THAT IS THE
BOTTOM LINE
THAT THAT
HE'S STILL WHO HE WAS. THERE
ARE JUST OTHER GUYS WHO
HAVE COME TO THE LEAGUE WHO
ARE DOING THINGS BETTER AND
THAT LEADS TO NUMBER FOUR
ON THE LIST WHO WEARS NUMBER
FOUR
FOR THE HOUSTON TEXANS FOR
NOW, WE'LL LIKELY NEVER PLAY
FOR THE TEXANS AGAIN AND
REMEMBER THIS IS JUST A
FOOTBALL ASSESSMENT THAT SAYS,
NOTHING'S RIGHT WITH THE
OFF-FIELD ISSUES
OF DESHAUN WATSON. BUT
CHRIS HAS YOU HAVE SAID FOR
THE PAST FEW YEARS.
DESHAUN WATSON.
SO FREAKING AWESOME. HE IS
COMES IN AT NUMBER 4
ON THE LIST. NOW.
HOW DID YOU ULTIMATELY DRAW
THE LINE BETWEEN
BETWEEN? BECAUSE I HAVE A
FEELING HE CAME DOWN TO WILSON
OR WATSON FOR, FOR
WHAT GAVE
WATSON THE BUMP OVER
WHILST I THINK, YOU KNOW, I
THINK THE BIG THING IS I THINK
WATSON IS MORE TALENTED AT
THIS POINT IN HIS CAREER THAN
RUSSELL WILSON. I THINK
HIS ARM STRONGER. I THINK HE'S
A BETTER ATHLETE. AND
HONESTLY,
YOU KNOW, HE'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONSISTENT IN HIS
DECISION MAKING AND THROWING
THE FOOTBALL THAN RUSSELL
WILSON. IT'S NOT
A LOT BUT A LITTLE BIT YOU
KNOW, DESHAUN WATSON IS THE
GREATEST. HE'S GREAT FOR ME
AND ALL MY ARGUMENTS TO GO
LIKE
NOBODY ARGUES THAT THE JEAN
WATSON ISN'T A TOP FIVE
QUARTERBACK
AND FOOTBALL. THERE YOU GO.
YOU GOT A FRANCHISE
QUARTERBACK, HE'S THE MAN.
WELL, WHEN YOU HAVE CRAP
AROUND THEM, YOU STILL COULD
GO FOUR AND
12 EVEN WITH THE MAN AT
QUARTERBACK AND HE HAD CRAP
AROUND HIM. I MEAN
AGAIN
4 AND 12 THEY COULD HAVE BEEN
EASILY
SEVEN AND NINE IF THE REST OF
THE TEAM DIDN'T CRAP AND
P DOWN
THEIR LEG AT
TIMES. I MEAN THEY HAD A
TRUCK. WELL YOU KNOW,
THINK ABOUT, YOU KNOW AGAIN
4 AND 12 AND WE'RE GONNA PUT
THAT ON HIS GRAVESTONE THAT HE
WAS
BORN 12 INTO IT.
WHAT WAS A BAD SNAP IN THE
COLTS GAME WHEN THEY'RE ON
WHAT THE
TWO-YARD LINE TO WIN THE
FOOTBALL GAME, YOU KNOW,
KIKI
CUTIE CUTIE FUMBLES ON THE TWO
YARD LINE, A FEW WEEKS LATER
AGAINST THE COLTS. THEY COULD
HAVE BEAT THE TITANS.
I MEAN, THERE WAS SO MANY
CLOSE GAMES WHERE YOU GO
THERE, ONLY IN THIS GAME
FOR ONE REASON
THEY HAVE A CRAPPY DEFENSE.
NO RUN.
AND THEY WERE IN IT BECAUSE A
NUMBER
FOUR THAT'S ALL THERE IS TO BE
SAID,
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT OFF
THE FIELD. LIKE YOU SAID ON
THE FIELD, THE GUYS ARE
SUPER STAR. HE'S TOUGH AS
HELL.
HE WANTS TO BEAT YOU FROM THE
POCKET. HE STAYS IN THE POCKET
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
AND
HAS A GREAT FEEL OF LIKE,
OKAY, NOW IT'S TIME TO GET OUT
AND MAKE SOMETHING HAPPEN
AND EXCUSE ME IS I'M CHOKING
ON MYSELF, BUT
HE
HE'S A REALLY SPECIAL FOOTBALL
PLAYER AND THEY JUST NEED TO
SUPPORT HIM A LITTLE BIT MORE
AND HELP THEM OUT.
AFTER THEY TRADED DEANDRE
HOPKINS, YOU SAW A SILVER
LINING THERE.
IN SO FAR AS HE REMOVED A
CRUTCH
FOR
DESEAN WASPS. YES, THAT HE
WOULDN'T FEEL COMPELLED TO
STARE DOWN DEANDRE HOPKINS,
THROW IT TO DEANDRE HOPKINS,
KIND OF LIKE A COROLLARY TO
THE OBJ THING WHERE YOU JUST
THROW TO THE OPEN GUY. YOU
DON'T WORRY ABOUT WHO IT IS.
DID YOU SEE GROWTH IN
WATSON LAST YEAR BY NOT HAVING
HOPKINS THERE? BECAUSE HE HAD
HIS BEST YEAR EVER
THAT HE DIDN'T HAVE DEANDRE
HOPKINS,
THAT'S IT. I MEAN, HE HAD HIS
BEST YEAR
EVER THAT
THAT'S IT NOW. DID IT MAKE
THEIR TEAM BETTER? THAT
DEANDRE HOPKINS WAS THERE?
ABSOLUTELY NOT. THEY NEEDED A
GUY THAT CAN MAKE SOME CRAZY
PLAYS. LIKE, WE SAW HIM, MAKE
AN ARIZONA THAT MAYBE THEY
WOULD HAVE WON A GAME OR TWO
THAT THEY DIDN'T,
IF HE WAS ON THE FIELD.
BUT I DO THINK OVERALL,
YES, THE PLAY FROM
WATSON WAS BETTER, YOU KNOW,
YOU IT WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A
CRUTCH,
YOU KNOW, WHEN IN DOUBT WAIT,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M LOOKING
AT. I'LL JUST WE THROW IT
TO DEANDRE HOPKINS.
OH WAIT. THIS I SHOULDN'T
THROW TO HIM HERE IN THIS
COVERAGE, BUT I'M GONNA GO
BECAUSE HE'S DEANDRE HOPKINS.
LISTEN. I KNOW THERE'S SOME OF
THAT THAT GOES ON, BUT
YEAH, NOW HE USED
MORE OF THE SYSTEM, MORE OF
THE WEAPONS, YOU KNOW, THAT
WERE AVAILABLE
AND IT BECAME A LITTLE BIT
LESS OF A,
I DON'T KNOW WHERE,
HE'S GOING TO GO WITH THE
FOOTBALL. HE PLAYED PHENOMENAL
HE REALLY DID.
AND YOU KNOW, I JUST CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH ABOUT THE GUY ON THE
FIELD AND WHAT HE DID HE JUST
THEY GOT TO THEY GOT TO HAVE A
DEFENSE, THEY NEED A LITTLE
BIT OF A RUNNING GAME.
THEY NEED A,
YOU KNOW, LEGIT,
NUMBER-ONE RECEIVER
TO BE ALONGSIDE A, HE'S NOT
GONNA BE THERE. HE'S NO, NOT
THEREFORE, I'M JUST SAYING, I
KNOW, I'M JUST SAYING THAT'S
WHAT THEY NEED. IF EVERYBODY
WANTS TO SEE WHAT THE GUY CAN
REALLY BE AND HOW
HOW SPECIAL HE IS.
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT WHAT
HE CAN REALLY BE WITH ANOTHER
TEAM. WHETHER IT'S THE EAGLES,
THE DOLPHINS, THE BRONCOS,
OR SOMEONE ELSE, WHETHER IT'S
THIS YEAR, OR NEXT YEAR, WE'RE
GOING TO FIND OUT AND THAT'S
ANOTHER MYSTERY,
T WILL BE
SOLVED TO A CERTAIN EXTENT
WHILE WE ARE ON HIATUS,
ALTHOUGH
WE'LL BE TRACKING THIS,
YOUR DEATH CAREFULLY,
IT PRO FOOTBALL TALK.COM
WILL. HE SHOW UP FOR TRAINING
CAMP? WILL HE BE PLACED ON THE
COMMISSIONER EXEMPT LIST? WILL
THEY
DECIDE BEFOREHAND? WHICH I
THINK THEY SHOULD WHETHER OR
NOT HE'LL BE ON PAID LEAVE AND
LET HIM KNOW. LET THE TEXANS
KNOW LET OTHER TEAMS KNOW
SO PEOPLE CAN MAKE DECISIONS.
GOOD DECISION, SMART DECISIONS
ABOUT THE FUTURE.
HERE'S ONE THING THOUGH, WHERE
I THINK DESHAUN WATSON CAN
BE EVEN BETTER AND I'M GOING
TO COUCH THIS
AS A POTENTIAL POSITIVE, NOT
AS A NEGATIVE, BUT I
TALK TO SOMEONE VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT, RUSSELL
WILSON AND DESHAUN WATSON, NOT
THAT LONG AGO. YEAH, WILSON
FALLS INTO THE CATEGORY OF
THE TOM. BRADY
PEYTON, MANNING
DREW BREES LIVE
BREATHE
SHIRT,
SLEEP POOP.
RIGHT FOOT.
PARDON ME. YEAH. BUT IT'S
AN UH, NEVER-ENDING OBSESSION
AND IT'S WORK. WORK WORK,
WORK WORK, WORK, WORK.
DESHAUN. WATSON IS NOT THERE,
YET.
NOT FORGET THEIR RIGHT, BUT
HE'S NOT THERE YET. HE
DOESN'T PUT IN THE WORK AWAY
FROM THE FACILITY AND HE
DOESN'T NECESSARILY SHOW UP
EARLY AND STAY LATE
NOT NOT QUITE TO THE DEGREE. I
REMEMBER THERE WAS THE
NARRATIVE ABOUT BEN
ROETHLISBERGER AT ONE POINT
AND I GUESS TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT, YOU CAN SAY IT'S STILL
THERE, BUT BUT
WE'LL WATSON GROW INTO
THE GUY?
WHO IS
CONSUMED ALL THE TIME WITH
FOOTBALL,
DOING EVERYTHING, HE CAN TO
GET THE ABSOLUTE MOST OUT OF
HIS SKILLS AND KENNY SQUEEZE
OUT
MORE IF HE DOES THAT
THAT'S THE REAL QUESTION I
HAVE BECAUSE I THINK HE COULD
BE EVEN BETTER THAN
4 BECAUSE
HE'S WHERE HE IS
WITHOUT THE ALL-CONSUMING
OBSESSION THAT A RUSSELL
WILSON OR A TOM, BRADY WOULD
HAVE IF
WATSON DEVELOPS THAT
DOES HE
THREATENED PATRICK MAHOMES?
WELL, HE'S THE BEST
QUARTERBACK AND
GOD, THAT TYPE OF TALENT. I
MEAN, HE'S GOT TOP, YOU KNOW,
123 TYPE OF TALENT IN THE
LEAGUE. THERE'S NO DOUBT HE
DOES. YOU'RE RIGHT. THAT'S THE
NEXT THE NEXT STEP.
I MEAN I, YOU KNOW, AND I
DON'T WANT TO
PORTRAY THIS IS A GUY THAT'S
STILL I THINK A STUDENT OF THE
GAME AND WORKS HARD AND DOES
THOSE THINGS. BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT. LIKE THERE'S
A NEXT LEVEL AND SOMETIMES YOU
DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHERE THAT NEXT LEVEL IS,
UNLESS YOU'VE BEEN AROUND A
GUY THAT'S BEEN AROUND ONE OF
THOSE GUYS, YOU MENTIONED
OR, YOU KNOW? YEAH, THERE'S
THERE'S SOMEBODY'S GOT TO SHOW
YOU THE WAY
TO A DEGREE.
YEAH, SO I'M SURE BUT WE'VE
SEEN ASPECTS OF WHAT WAS
THAT GAME LAST YEAR THAT THEY
LOST AND HE STAYED ON THE
FIELD, REMEMBER, LIKE AFTER
THE GAME, IT WAS AN HOUR AND A
HALF AFTER THE GAME. HE WAS
OUT THERE WITH HIS QUARTERBACK
COACH GOING THROUGH
READS AND THINGS LIKE THAT. SO
I DO THINK WE'RE SEEING
MATURITY BUT YET HE'S PROBABLY
BEEN, YOU KNOW, AGAIN GUYS
LIKE BREEZE AND BRADY,
THEY HAVE TO BE LIKE THAT TO
A DEGREE,
YOU KNOW? THERE WAS NO OTHER
CHOICE, THEY NEEDED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ALL THAT
SOMETIMES THE WATSONS
MAHOMES AND THE
ALLENS OF THE
THEY THEY, YOU KNOW, AGAIN
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO KICK KICK
ASS, SORRY, LONDON.
YOU KNOW, JUST WITH THEIR
GREAT, PHYSICAL ABILITY, THEIR
WHOLE LIFE. SO THEY'RE NOT
ALWAYS LIKE I GOT TO GET IN
THERE AT 5:45 AND
UNDERSTAND THE SQUARE ROOT OF
64 AND UNDERSTAND THIS
BLITZ, AND THAT BLITZ AND NO
EVER, YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHERE
YES,
THAT'S WHERE THE SEASONING
PROFESSIONALISM COMES INTO
TOWN BUT MIKE ONE THING I
DON'T WANT TO LOSE HERE IS THE
GUY'S AWESOME. HE LEAVES
REALLY WHEN I BROKE IT DOWN
BETWEEN HIM AND RUSSELL
WILSON.
YOU JUST
I THINK HE'S A MORE CONSISTENT
THROWER HE LEAVES LESS
YARDS ON THE FIELD THAN
RUSSELL WILSON.
IN THE FOOTBALL, YOU KNOW,
THERE WAS A FEW GAMES EVEN
WHEN I WENT BACK TO WATCH THE
YOU KNOW, WILSON A FEW WEEKS
AGO, WHERE I WENT
MAN. THERE'S SOME PLACE HERE
WHERE IT'S DK MET CAP,
ONE-ON-ONE, YOU CAN'T LET THE
DEFENSE GET AWAY WITH THIS.
YOU CAN'T YOU GOTTA THROW IT
TO DK. HE'S
ONE-ON-ONE AGAINST SOME SCHLEP
CORNER
AND YOU GOT TO DO IT. THIS IS
GOING TO HELP YOU OUT THE TEAM
OUT AND ALL THAT WATSON
DOESN'T MAKE THOSE MISTAKES.
OH, IT'S BRANDON COOKS ON AN
AVERAGE CORNER. WE HAVE
TO LASER BEAM. OH THERE'S
NOBODY OPEN, YOU KNOW HE
HAS AN AGGRESSIVE DOWN THE
FIELD THROWING SEE
DUMB, HE DOES NOT GET A LOT OF
DINKIN DUNK COMPLETIONS AND
HE IS A PRETTY DAMN GOOD
DECISION MAKER TO GO ALONG. I
MEAN, LOOK AT THIS,
EIGHT POINT NINE YARDS PER
ATTEMPT,
70 PERCENT COMPLETION
PERCENTAGE
FORTY, EIGHT HUNDRED YARDS,
NO RUNNING GAME. YOU KNEW THEY
WERE GOING TO DROP BACK AND
THROW THE BALL EVERY GAME
ALL GAME, HE WAS THEIR ONLY
HOPE
AND THAT'S WHY I, YOU KNOW,
AGAIN,
GOTTA PRAISE THE GUY FOR WHAT
HE DOES ON THE FIELD BECAUSE
HE'S VERY SPECIAL.
AND THEN INTERIM COACH FOR 12
GAMES TO EXACTLY
O'BRIEN, FOR A GAME.
THAT'S RIGHT. I'M STILL
PERPLEXED THAT. YOU THINK
THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTION OF
WHAT IS THE SQUARE? ROOT OF 64
IS DIFFICULT? NO, WELL,
YOU'RE RIGHT. I SHOULD HAVE
SAID A HIGHER ONE. WE WERE
RIGHT BUT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
I MEANT
ARE, YOU KNOW, GETTING SQUARE
ROOT OF 64, IS
ITS EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I WAS PRETTY GOOD AT
MATH BUT US, THAT GUY
WELL I, YOU KNOW, YOUR WORK
AND IT'S PROBABLY
JAGUAR, SEE BEHIND YOU.
TELLING YOU THAT WE'RE REALLY
GOOD IN MATH. I WAS OKAY,
YES, I WAS. I WAS PRETTY GOOD.
OKAY,
BUT
YES, WHAT? BUT
THAT'S
YOU KNOW,
IT'S THE SAME THING TO WEAR,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T LIKE ALWAYS
THAT WOULD LIKE A BREEZE,
BRADY ALL THAT, YOU KNOW I
GET THAT BUT THESE ARE YOUNG
GUYS WHO ARE FINDING THEIR
WAYS AND THEY ARE
MOLDED A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY
AND HE WILL LEARN TO BE THAT
MACHINE,
YOU KNOW, MENTALLY LIKE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND UNDERSTAND
HOW TO PUT THAT LITTLE EXTRA
WORK
IN TO MAYBE GET THEM THE TEAM